attack on Titan showing us some of the
best action scenes in the recent decade
from 3d maneuver gear acrobatics to
full-on titan brawls the show definitely
knows how to deliver visuals and
action-packed scenes so today we're
counting down the top 10 scenes in the
beloved and hyped series sit back relax
and try not to bite your fingers off
we start off with Aaron's first fight
against the female Titan after
witnessing the female Titan murdering
his new allies Aaron loses it and
transforms himself into his Titan form
to take her on himself the woods around
the pair provide a closed space for them
to brawl and we quickly learn as does
Aaron how strong the female Titan truly
is she makes quick work of his attacks
and turns them around on him and despite
being a Titan it shown throughout the
arc that the female Titan is unlike the
others as she has the ability to think
logically she waits for the perfect
moment to attack and turns the tables on
the rage-filled
Aaron he is soon defeated but the female
Titan isn't done yet as Mikasa watches
the female Titan rips open Titan Aaron's
neck takes his human form and leaves
before Mikasa can even call Aaron's name
next we have Levi's rage mode versus
Titan while not part of the original
series this OVA episode helps us
understand levi is more than the captain
that we were introduced to it takes us
back to Levi's past showing how he
became part of the survey corpse we get
a taste of his skills when he comes
across the severed head of his dear
friend Isabel who'd been brutally
murdered by a Titan moments before he
just came on the scene what happens next
makes us consider exactly who's safe
with the walls up levi destroys the
titan who murdered his friend not caring
about the damage done to him simply just
attacking in a rage with his loss and
despair slowly consuming him when the
battles over the clear winner is levi as
he annihilated the titan levi slef
trying to hold himself together as the
weight of his loss finally takes its
toll
[Music]
number eight none other than the final
fight between Erin and the female Titan
the end of the fair season came with a
big fight in an even bigger cliffhanger
that lasted for years and he was
revealed to be the female Titan and was
soon causing all sorts of problems
inside the innermost wall however her
attack would be challenged by Aaron
arriving and attempting to put a stop to
her the fight goes back and forth
between the pair but with the serve a
corpse and Mikasa helping Aaron deliver
several key blows to Annie she's
ultimately taken down it appears Annie
wasn't willing to admit defeat and
instead of allowing her conscious self
to be taken in she crystallizes herself
instead fast leaving everyone wondering
why she did it
next up it's Aaron vs. Reiner after
outing themselves as the colossal and
armored Titans Burton and Reiner
prepared to fight their former allies as
the survey Cubs fight off the colossal
Titan Eren goes against the armored
Titan Breiner unlike his usual fights
evarin realizes he's outmatched and
tries to play smart by attacking Reiner
with Annies techniques in order to gain
the upper hand for a while it looks like
Aaron might pull ahead and win as Erin
leaves Reiner with serious damage
including ripping off his arm and
chipping away at his armor the fight
ends with Aaron's defeat as bertolt
steps in and helps his ally out leaving
not only Aaron for us hoping for a
second round to even the score
[Music]
moving on to number six we have aaron's
retrieval at the end of attack on titan
season two the survey corpse are faced
with their biggest challenge yet
rescuing aaron from the hands of Bertot
the colossal titan and Reinert the
armored Titan as the battle rages on
Armin tries to talk some sense into the
colossal Titan who's holding Eren
hostage as the armored Titan listens in
and is ready to strike Armand down as
I'm in talks though bertok isn't swayed
by his former friends words however it
appears that a win used bertolt and
rhinos moment of distraction thanks to
Armin as the opening he needed to save
era me
okay before we continue I'd like to
thank a team for sponsoring this video
their game of Valkyrie Connect is a
fast-paced fantasy RPG based loosely on
Norse mythology
it contains legendary heroes villains
and gods with over-the-top special
abilities which can be unleashed with a
single tap all characters in the game
can be evolved to max rarity equipped
with various kinds of gear players can
join co-op raid battles against massive
bosses to earn various rewards including
the bosses themselves as useable
characters multiple pvp arenas are also
available to face up against other
players they're exclusively
collaborating with attack on Titan
Season 2 so you can find five exclusive
characters from the series including
Eren Mikasa Levi Krista and Han G you
can even fight the armored Titan on a
special stage directly from the anime
defeating the armored Titan will offer a
chance and unlocking it as a player
character right now they're holding a
contest where five of you can win $5,000
is comment your in-game player names and
player ID so don't forget to check out
the game I'll leave the link in the
description
[Music]
number five its Levi's fight against
Kenny squad many fans were skeptical of
attack on Titan season three seeing as
the majority of the fights would be
between humans and not Titans
but if Levi's handling of Kenny squad
tells us anything it's a no matter who
Levi's fighting he's always going to
look badass despite being outnumbered in
taking major damage Levi is able to hold
off Kenny squad and even make his escape
before they know what's happening with
scenes ranging from an old western
shootout in a bar to a gorgeous the
animated rooftop chase this fight was
one of the best in the 3rd season and of
course involved everyone's favorite
captain
at number 4 we have Levi's squad vs.
Kenny squad when trying to defeat an
experienced squad of trained Titan
killers no one other than Levi could
create a team capable of not only out
maneuvering Kenny squad but also showing
how much deeper their trust and
communication is if one member was in
trouble another would be straight in
there helping them out with Levi and
Mikasa battling out front and others
like Kearney and Sasha assisting from
the fact that was clay Kenny squad would
be defeated in no time and allow our
favorite squad members to continue their
mission this showed us that while skills
are valuable in titan killing it's also
important to have someone trustworthy to
what your back
at number three we have the female Titan
versus Levi the survey corpse his failed
attempt to retrieve a possible key to
defeating the Titans in Aaron's basement
ended in a way that left many of our
jaws wide open Levi's squad who'd
quickly found a way into our hearts with
their sense of family and dedication to
their leader are murdered by the female
Titan in an attempt to get Eren to
escape once Levi comes across the bodies
of his fallen comrades his deep frown
and grave looking eyes are enough to
tell us that something big is about to
go down
Levi seeks out the female Titan as Eren
is about to fall in battle the fight may
not have lasted long but Levi's skills
and expertise were enough to let us know
that he's not someone to become an enemy
of no matter who you are
[Music]
right
[Music]
having wisdom each day
[Music]
next we have the survey corpse versus
Reiner and bertolt Bertolt was one of
the original trainee corpse we were
introduced to and like Reiner many hated
trying to accept the idea that he was
the one who caused the initial crisis at
the fall of wall Maria to make matters
worse Reiner was revealed to be the
armored Titan who helped greatly in
trying to tear down the other two walls
of humanity's civilization seeing as the
pair were the enemy it meant the survey
corpse would soon come to clash with the
armored and colossal Titan in order to
stop any possible current or future
plots of the pair in the end though
Armin sacrifices himself in order to
help push his allies to victory and left
many of us watching in shock
armed with thunder Spears to attempt to
take down Reiner the survey corpse
attempt to push him back while Aaron
takes his final stand against bertolt
[Applause]
finally at number one we have Levi
versus beast Titan in one of the high
points of attack on Titan season 3
Levi confronts the beast Titan in an
epic duel duel might be stretching it
though as the fight simply showed us
once more while Levi is indeed humanity
strongest soldier Levi waste no time in
systematically dismantling the beasts
tightened down to size he's no stranger
to fighting Titans for his relentless
assault coming off the heels of one of
the biggest sacrifices in the series is
something that we've yet to witness with
no time to mount a successful defense
the Beast Titan gets destroyed by
humanity's strongest soldier
[Applause]
attack on titan will forever be
remembered as a phenomenal series from
its unique animation incredible arcs and
characters to the excellent fights and
stunning action displays each new season
left viewers craving more from the
series and as we get closer to the end
it can only make us try to figure out
what else is to come and if the biggest
fight has yet to be shown only time will
tell what's left in store for us but
from what we've seen so far it will no
doubt be impressive please make sure to
LIKE comment subscribe and let us know
what your favorite action scene in
attack on titan has been don't forget to
check out our sponsors game Valkyrie
connect I'll leave the link in the
description see you later everyone
[Music]
[Music]